huh do people get panicky sometimes a
really kind of panicky hey what's going
on everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings
and today we welcome Dan levy to the hot
seat he's the co creator and star of pop
TV's hit series shits Creek which just
wrapped its sixth and final season and
we'll hit streaming on Netflix later
this year dan levy welcome to the show
thank you so much for having me I want
to say this is one of my dreams come
true so it's a big moment for me I just
shot a movie with Kristen Stewart and
the first question I asked her was about
hot ones what it was like how she
thought it went and Kristen being just
like the coolest person I've ever met
basically was like yeah Jews it's fine
and I was thinking to myself if I ever
get the opportunity to do this show I
don't think it's gonna be fine for me so
she's basically like made it impossible
for me to be anything but cool today
[Music]
I'm ready Africa that's very good
[Music]
so shits Creek has inspired such cult
fandom I think would be remiss not to
just get into the weeds of that show
here on the first wing factor fiction
you and Noah Reid had to down an entire
bottle of Prosecco to work up the nerve
to do that simply the best number in
season four yeah I am I'm not a
performer in that nature and I certainly
don't dance often so I knew that we were
shooting the scene the two of us just
like casually started having some
glasses of Prosecco and by the time that
we were ready to shoot we had realized
that we had downed pretty good students
out here bottle and what you see on the
show is the direct result of a lot of
method acting I've heard you say that
this last season is like a love letter
to the fans and without giving too much
away are spoiling it for the people who
are waiting to watch the show on Netflix
is there an easter egg that's your
favorite that you've woven into the plot
we had this running gag of our town sign
where the joke was you know the couple
on the town sign looked like they're
having sex and in actuality it's just a
sister bending over to get some water
and the brother behind her but the
illusion is something sexual so
originally in season one there was a
sign that had to be put up on top of the
sign to clarify don't worry it's his
sister so by the last season we did a
little play on the confusion of brother
sister husband and wife that I thought
was was a fun little callback and then
finally do you have a favorite
vocabulary word that you've learned
writing for Katherine era's character
Moira all of it was it I want to say
that they've stuck I want to say that my
vocabulary actually expanded through
this process it did not her calling me a
disgruntled Pelican was a fun little
description that made it into the show
that I was quite proud of it was such a
joy to write for Katherine and to write
for a character whose vocabulary is so
left-of-centre it just constantly forced
our team of writers to be thinking of
different
saying very simple things and it was I
will miss that a lot
so far so good for me so I know that
you're very involved in everyone's
wardrobe on shits Creek not just your
own character what's the math or process
for finding clothes that make sense for
a show shot in small-town America for us
it was a lot of consignment shopping
because we didn't have a budget to buy
the kind of designer clothes that we
needed to but it was really important
for me to authenticate the characters in
the show by actually having them wear
clothes the people who pay attention to
fashion might be interested in so the
whole process led to building that kind
of relationship between the humor in the
show and the and the Wardrobe how do you
describe the aesthetic appeal of Rick
Owens to someone who knows nothing about
fashion it sort of just looks like
everything's dropped a bit the
proportions have like elongated your
t-shirts are much longer the crotch of
your pants is about a foot lower than
where you'd expect it it is the most
comfortable clothes I have ever worn and
I took a lot of it home with me when the
show when the show ended and then you do
a lot of things well but one thing that
really stands out to me and they're
endure wearing one today
it's your impeccable taste when it comes
to sweaters are there any bruisers and
don'ts when it comes to shopping for
sweaters and then of course the upkeep
well the upkeep is important you have to
know how to store them you need to know
you know the quality of the fiber moths
love sweaters so it's about getting some
cedar kind of in and around the drawers
where you're keeping them I feel like
for menswear now more than ever before
we have so many more options available
to us than when I was growing up so the
knitwear game across the board I think
has just been raised and I'm very glad
that it has and then finally as a mall
employee turned fit God do you have a
snap reaction to this news of Kanye West
designing a Yeezy line for gap I will
say that I you know
the the gap collaborations that they've
done over the years and gap and GQ have
done a lot of collaborations together
with menswear designers they've all been
great so I'll take a pair of sweatpants
[Music]
all right so this one number three I
pull a habanero yep okay
[Music]
okay so that has a kick to it that the
other ones didn't it's our first sort of
taking it up a notch moment it's like a
deep pepper but it's almost like a fruit
it is a deep pepper mm-hmm I got um just
so you know I have three different
beverages for today I have a milkshake I
have some soda and I have some water and
I just wanted to make sure that I was
able to see what calm
what combats the heat best well please
report your findings I'm always I'm
always late for the milkshake the
milkshake is doing well for me so from
reading articles about your time at MTV
it seems like you'd agree with something
that I've been thinking about for the
longest and that is that red carpet
correspondent is the single worst job in
all of media oh man I was so bad at it
I will I will give a lot of credit to
red carpet reporters because for an
award show for example you get a book
this thick of every single person who is
going to walk down that red carpet and
you have to learn not only who they are
what they look like but also their
entire filmography and usually some kind
of like quirky trivia and then it's just
trying desperately to get a soundbite
out of someone as they pass right by you
it was not it was not fun but there are
I mean there are some people that have
mastered the art of it I was certainly
not one of them do you think that your
experience doing interviews did anything
to change or inform how you approach
being a talk show guest I mean you do
such a beautiful job of it but I think
obviously the questions have to be kind
of interesting but also people have to
talk and I you know as someone who has
interviewed a lot you know if nothing
was worse than getting one-word answers
out of somebody and then running out of
your questions but you still have a
chunk of time left
you've gotta have a level of charm and I
think that's my big thing through any
kind of interview situation is like
you've got to have genuine interest and
the people you're talking to because I
feel like people at home can just see
right through it when it's when it's not
very genuine
I quite like this one
this is very flavorful mm-hmm - so
you're the latest and illustrious line
of Canadian hot ones guests which
include Michael Cera Matty Matheson
Shawn Mendes and now you Dan levy as a
Degrassi alum and Toronto native do you
recall your first ever meeting with
Drake it was at an airport and he and
some of the Degrassi kids were getting
off a plane as I was getting on and we
kind of said hi to each other in passing
and we had never met before but I think
being in Canadian television you kind of
had a general awareness of who each
other are and then years later I was
sitting in a restaurant and he was
sitting across the restaurant it was
just that game of like I don't want to
go and like say something and then
happen like not remember and anyway at
the end of his meal he came up and just
said hi as he was walking by and I was
like well there you go
I guess he does remember how do you
describe her explain Degrassi for people
who only know it from those Drake
wheelchair Jimmy miebs well it started
in the 80s and it's like a very earnest
serious approach to high school drama
that always has like a cautionary tale
element to it if you're an actor in
Canada you will inevitably kind of go
through the process of appearing on
Degrassi and it is a coming-of-age
moment for all Canadian actors and I did
it quite late in the game
it was an experience that was quite
interesting
[Music]
so this impulse in the mouth it's a very
fragrant bouquet of flavors that almost
tastes like it almost tastes like you've
just gotten a big whiff of someone's
armpit
it is like a gamy musky flavor that's
not going away all right Dan well while
you wash that down we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
grammar we do a deep dive on our guest
sense grandpa interesting pictures that
need more context I'd be remiss not to
ask you about your dog Redmond what are
your thoughts on Los Angeles dog culture
like is it insufferable or is it kind of
sweet that everyone kind of celebrities
--is their pets I think it's probably a
bit of both I think everyone needs to
just put their phones down for a second
and just generally reevaluate what's
going on I think if you're getting mad
at people for standing in the shot of
your dog's Instagram post you've got
bigger problems on your hands do you
have a favorite keepsake from the set of
shits Creek the cafe tropical jerseys I
think would be at the top of my list I
have taken home a handful of those menus
from the show and we we had them made
kind of oversized so that you couldn't
actually open them without looking like
a total idiot I kept a bunch of those I
kept a bunch of the little icon I cut
some framed illustrations from our
little motel room I I am NOT good with
letting go so I've actually taken most
elusive things from our set and just
kind of have them in my garage yeah it
was a tough thing to say goodbye to
those sets so yeah
[Music]
this is a heavy dousing
that has some of that pepper poison in
it a lot of pepper poison on that one
okay all right okay one thing that
stands out to me is that you proactively
chose to end shits Creek and it's such a
character driven drama that you probably
could have done another hundred plus
episodes
can you talk through the why of that
it's something that I'd associate with
British comedies even or if you think
about the office or Phoebe Waller
bridges fleabag yeah the storytelling of
television is so important and you know
I am such a fan of television then I
understand how quickly a legacy of a
show can be tarnished by overextending
itself and for me it was so important
that people walk away at the end of our
show still loving it as much as they did
when they started so a lot of that I
think was just deciding this is as far
as we can go right now with quality
keeping the quality up making sure that
the stories are strong because I would
hate to take a show past its expiry date
and how people suddenly say yeah I
watched it until episode six and then it
sort of got that's all you want my
tongues on fire my tongue is on fire I
have watched people knife and fork their
wings so as to not get the hot sauce on
their lips
I respect the choice but if you're gonna
do it I feel like it should be the whole
experience so I've just I'm saying this
because I do have a knife and fork in
front of me and I've opted not to use
them right now let the record show all
right here we go
that's that gets right into the back of
the throat that is that's full-coverage
that's not going away anytime soon no
we're in it we are you can select each
of these sauces thank you for asking
actually I'm not sure how much time you
spend in Williamsburg Brooklyn but
there's a hot sauce store there called
heat mist and the guy who runs it he's
kind of like our hot sauce sensei so we
go to him and then we get all these hot
sauce makers take old ones out shuffle
it up every season and and then what we
want though is exactly what you're
experiencing which is this Symphony
little tongue will let throat he snaps
that whole Rubik's Cube into place so
your father comedy legend Eugene Levy
played Jim's dad at American Pie a film
that explicitly deals with awkward
father teen relationship dynamics uh-huh
what do you remember about being 15
years old and that being the number one
movie in the world it must have been a
unique role to see your dad play
especially at that age
[Music]
you know I think a lot of at the time my
[ __ ] a lot of people came up and asked
me whether the movie was based on my
life my story is way less interesting I
did not have sex with a pie
unfortunately Oh uh-huh
how would you rank yourself against
others who've played your dad's son on
camera I feel like Jason Biggs did a
more successful job at it than I did and
I ran into Jason recently and it's in a
way it feels like every time I see him
like he's a strange sort of extended
member of my family but I'm very at
peace with the fact that Jason did a
very good job of playing his son and I
think he still prefers Jason to me let's
be honest okay all right this is to bomb
beyond insanity okay be careful
oh no what is this oh man
that's not pleasant this is not pleasant
careful around your eyes careful around
your eyes do people get panicky
sometimes I'm feeling kind of panicky
okay remember remember you're in the
comfort of your own home so before your
career took off in Hollywood I know that
you strung together a series of odd jobs
some of which you used for inspiration
and writing shits Creek as someone who
worked in a video rental store what are
people who've never browsed the shelves
at blockbuster missing out on
I don't know I don't know what they're
missing in addition to co-hosting the
Great Canadian baking show I know that
he worked in a literal bakery what do
you think is the goat bakery smell
probably like probably like a like a
baked butter though chocolate chip
cookie you're a quest song or something
like that anytime that something's
drenched in butter but that cooks I
think there's like a very like
quintessential smell I ate a lot of that
bakery like a lot like I didn't have any
restraint at that bakery you also have
the rare distinction having worked at
ICM and then later on working in
Hollywood and ICM for those who don't
know is one of the world's biggest
talent agencies uh-huh what would shock
me about what my agent says or does
behind my back probably that all the
times you tried to get in touch with
them and they say they can't come to the
phone or they're out to lunch they're
not out to lunch and they can't come to
the phone they just don't
why do I find that one not to be as bad
is it because my mouth is now numb
you've already been smoked out we were
in the shower and now it's raining you
know who cares
uh-huh it comes in waves it really they
take shifts the heat I've used this
analogy before but it's like
professional wrestlers you know when
they start showboating in the ring
that's when someone takes a steel chair
and smashes it over their head that's
when you're in yeah that space where you
think that you're okay that they come
back and get you oh no what our figure
skating faces and then where does doing
a segment on them during the Vancouver
Olympics rank in terms of your
broadcasting accomplishments where did
you find these things
Google's figure skating faces you will
find a collection of the most wonderful
faces made by figure skaters who are
sort of like like caught mid axel
there's a lot of like high intensity
spinning that happens that actually like
morphs your face into all of these
different very funny contortions so we
would do this at this segment where we
would my brains working anymore
where we would just show kind of screen
grabs of all of these different figure
skaters at the Olympics who ended up
having these kind of very funny
contorted faces and yeah it was a big it
was a career highlight certainly enough
for you to bring it up now I'm burping
and Canada won the Olympics that year
and we won hockey you know is a very
proud moment for for us Canadians do you
have a two sentence review of the
lifetime original movie cyberstalker
it's bad
how about bad and if I was allowed a
third word it's very bad yeah that was
one of my first gigs as an actor and I
played a wheelchair ridden cyberstalker
murderer not to give the movie away and
then finally Cosmopolitan's guilty
pleasure or timeless classic when made
right with the fresh ingredients they
are very very refreshing
and I love a pink cocktail I'm not gonna
lie
reminds me of being on vacation alright
Dan levy
ah
that's perfect how much am i dab agin it
you know what it's up to you Dan it's up
to you right cheers Cheers
this has been a treat I can't say it was
entirely enjoyable but I had a great
time
hey we'll take that we'll take that well
I'd say that before I eat this so here
goes
[Music]
[Music]
all right dan levy here we are at the
final stop on our hot wing journey and
boy have we covered a lot of ground from
your MTB roots all the way through to
your emmy-nominated triumph that is
shits Creek but one thing that we've
overlooked is your column and flare
magazine where you used to do life
advice on everything from financial
responsibility to dealing with
technology overload so drawing on your
time as an Internet era philosopher
what's your directive to the fans
watching right now who maybe feel
withdrawn in this year of just physical
and social isolation I think what I
proved through your very thorough
investigation of my career is that I
really hustled in a variety of different
mediums to figure out what I wanted to
do with my life I think that one of the
great things that has come out of this
whole time has been a kind of connection
that I don't know if we necessarily
would have had had we not all been in
our homes a connection to what's going
on in the little connection to what's
going on socially a connection to what's
going on in our families and in our
friends I think before people were so
scared of even picking up the phone it
was a text culture we were in a way kind
of quite separated from one another and
you know I think in this has really kind
of brought people closer in a strange
way everyone's been at home and we've
all been communicating and we've all
been having conversations and those
conversations have been quite meaningful
so you know I think you have to kind of
see the good in the bad and and hope for
the best in terms of the future so you
know
yeah well if Dan levy says it then you
know it's the truth and look at you Dan
taken down ten scorching hot wings and
keeping the sweater on all the way
through Pitts look dry still looking
good glasses not even fogging up and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you my friend this
camera or possibly a camera B if you've
set one up let the people know what you
have going on in your life well I am sad
celebrating the end of the end of our
show it still has to has to drop on
Netflix in October which is which is
very exciting because it'll still be a
group of people who haven't seen the
last season yet but for now it's you
know just keep pushing forward and
creating some stuff that people like and
that kind of means something so that's
the goal and I'm keeping my fingers
crossed for it this was really really
something
I would say by the by the fact that my
milkshake is finished that was the most
effective tool in combating the heat
Cohen named Cola brand did not help me
very much
I find the carbonation almost made my
tongue like even worse and I didn't even
get to the water so so there you have it
there you have highly recommended
milkshake born from a delicious accident
the classic garlic Fresno Edition came
to be when we accidentally took a batch
of the classic and mixed it with ten
times the amount of garlic recommended
in the recipe whoops well you know what
at that point a star was born the
classic garlic Fresno Edition is now
available at heat nice calm heat nice
calm to pick up your bottle of the
classic garlic Fresno edition around
here we call it the Blue Label
[Music]
you